ten series GPUs have been taking a huge
hit recently but how low will they go
and when should you buy one
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies so as you guys
already know GPU prices have been
inflated for quite a while now due to a
variety of reasons such as inflated RAM
prices high cryptocurrency mining demand
and stock shortages from the video but
fortunately once the cryptocurrency
mining demand died off most of distress
on the GPU market was alleviated and GPU
prices finally started to fall and for
the last couple of months GPU practice
have been slowly falling and now many
GPUs are actually hitting MSRP finally
however this is just the beginning and
10 series cards will continue to drop in
price so when should you call it and
just buy a GPU first of all something to
keep in mind is that NVIDIA has abundant
inventory right now because they over
produced her GPUs in order to try to
satisfy the cryptocurrency mining demand
but once that demand died off the
average consumer wasn't willing to
overpay for GPUs and as a result sales
numbers related tanked and right now
anybody s left with a bunch of 10 series
GPUs and with Nvidia plan to release the
11 series very soon they need to get rid
of this inventory and as soon as
possible and as a result we will
probably see us deals like never before
on the 10 series for example even on
Black Friday last year which is usually
when the best GPU deals appeared it was
good to get a GTX 1084 $500 but just
last week you could get a gigabyte GTX
1084 450 dollars and even right now
there are plenty of Tenet's available
for $480 so as you guys can see GPU
prices are lower than ever before also
the pricing for the 10 series will only
get even better once the 11 series comes
out so make sure to keep that in mind as
well so considering all of that here's
how low I think
GPU level will go so starting off I
don't think you should buy the gtx 1050
or 1050 TI especially considering that
t x10 series is about to go obsolete so
it doesn't really make sense to buy the
most basic cards of that series also if
you want a good card for the future I
really recommend you at least buy a 1060
so starting off with the GTX 1016 3
gigabyte card on Black Friday you could
find this card from 170 to 180 dollars
and the MSRP of the GTX 1063 gigabyte
card is $200 and right now you can find
this card for 230 dollars so they're
quickly approaching MSRP and as a result
I believe it the GTX 1063 you buy card
will be offered for as little as $150
and you should aim to get this card for
anywhere between 150 to 180 dollars so
that's run ten to twenty five percent
savings over MSRP next up with the gtx
1066 gigabyte card its MSRP is $300 and
right now most gtx 1066 Kabaddi cards
are retailing for about 270 to 300
dollars on a black friday we saw prices
around $250 so right now I think we can
expect prices as low as $200 and I
believe that you guys should able to get
the gtx 1066 gigabyte card for less than
$250 so about fifteen to thirty percent
savings over MSRP as for the gtx 1070
its MSRP is three hundred and seventy
nine dollars but right now prices are
ranging from four hundred and five
hundred dollars so these prices still
have a ways to go and so I really don't
recommend that you guys buy a gtx 1070
please the lowest that I see its prices
going as $350 and even that is only
around 10% savings over MSRP so it's not
that significant to frequency r the gtx
1070 i recommend that you go ahead and
buy g6 1080 because in a lot of cases
the gtx 1080 is actually cheaper than
the GTX 1070 something else you may want
to consider is waiting for the gtx 1170
and getting that instead but it's
performance will be similar to the gtx
1080 and as price will be similar to the
gtx 770 however next up the gtx 1080 is
actually doing really well the MSRP of
the gtx 1080 is $600 and it was actually
originally
hundred dollars and right now you can
easily get a GTX 1084 anywhere from five
hundred to five hundred and fifty
dollars you can even get for four
hundred and eighty dollars if you don't
have any brand preferences and just last
week it was being offered for four
hundred fifty dollars based on all that
I think we can expect prices to drop
even as low as $400 so really you guys
should aim to get a GTX 1080 for less
than $450 and that would be a solid 25
to 30 percent savings over MSRP finally
the GTX 1080 Ti it's MSRP is $700 and
while some GPUs are being offered for
this price right now most 1080p eyes are
being offered for hi seven hundreds or
low eight hundreds so these prices don't
seem to be going down very quickly and
really I think the lowest of these
prices will go is $650 so that's not
even 10% savings plus all the things
considering the gtx 980ti
probably want the best performance
available on the market so I recommend
that you guys just get the gtx 1180
instead of the gtx 980ti busy low cost -
pretty much the same amount
well it'll perform a little bit better
plus you would be on the newest platform
and enjoy all the benefits that come
along with it
so overall asked for the 10 series I
don't recommend that you buy a 1050 or
1050 Ti because it just really isn't
that good of a long-term card and ask
for the 1070 it's so expensive right now
that it just makes more sense to buy a
1080 and same thing with the 1080i it's
so expensive that it really just makes
more sense to buy the 1180 when it comes
out as a result I believe that the best
cards to buy right now from the tennis
Ares are the 10 60 and 1080 if you want
a solid mid-level to be gaming card then
shoot to get a 10 63 gigabyte or 60
gabite card for twenty to twenty five
percent less than their respective MSRP
s and if you want a powerful gaming card
that will last you a very long time and
provide a great frame rates then try to
get a GTX 1080 for four hundred to four
hundred and fifty dollars and everyone
else considering other cards to just buy
one of these three cards or wait for the
AB
but that's all I have for you guys this
time do you guys think the GTX 10 series
is still worth it or are you going to be
waiting for the 11 series make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do it on my comments and I'm
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys liked this video that makes
your drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one but until next
time bye
[Music]